[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video going to be jumping all the
way back to the half-blood Prince and
the fateful scene where Snape murders
Dumbledore
one thing that if cusine question in the
comments section is why Dumbledore
seemingly pleaded with Snape before he
uttered the words of the killing curse
would end a temple to his life was he
just acting from the half-blood Prince
but somebody else had spoken Snipes name
quite softly Severus the sound
frightened Harry beyond anything he had
experienced all evening Dumbledore was
pleading Severus please so why would he
plead with Snape was he having second
thoughts or was this just a final
illusion that he wanted to create the
most obvious answer is yes this was all
just part of the act and a model was
playing the role of helpless dying old
man in his final moments
another more obvious reason is that
Snape was hesitant to kill dumbledore
this was no easy task for Snape and it
was the last thing that he wanted to do
Dumbledore had to plead with Snape to go
through with it just to make sure that
it was done and the draco soul would be
protected but one other thing that I
think is overlooked is that Dumbledore
really didn't want anyone else to be the
one to murder him if he was going to die
he wanted to die with some dignity and
he wanted to die instantly if it were up
to any of the other Death Eaters the new
model may have faced torture before
death the following excerpt supports
this you alone know whether it will harm
your soul to help an old man avoid pain
and humiliation said Dumbledore I asked
this one great favor to you Severus
because death is coming for me as surely
as the Chudley cannons who finished
bottom of this year's League
I confess I should prefer quick painless
exit to the protracted and messy affair
it will be if for instance Grayback is
involved
I hear Voldemort has recruited him or
dear Bellatrix who likes to play with
her food before she eats it his tone was
light but his blue eyes pissed Snape as
they had frequently pierced Harry as
though the soul they discussed was
visible to him at last
Snape gave another curt nod dumb model
clearly expresses that he would much
prefer a quick painless exit as many of
us would
think that when he pleads with Snape
there was also an undertone of this
desire in his voice there are lots of
reasons for why Snape should be the one
to kill him and receiving a painless
exit via the killing curse is one of
them Dumbledore is clearly horrified at
the prospect what someone like Bellatrix
or Fenrir Greyback would do with him is
that you Henry asked Dumbledore that's
right
rasps the other pleased to see me
Dumbledore no I cannot say that I am
Venu a great back grinned showing
pointed teeth blood trickled down his
chin and he licked his lips slowly
obscenely but you know how much I like
kids
Dumbledore am i now to take it you are
attacking even without the full moon
this is most unusual you've developed a
taste for human flesh that cannot be
satisfied once a month that's right Zedd
gray back
shox ooh that doesn't it a model
frightens you well I cannot pretend it
does not disgust me a little sad
Dumbledore and gray back raised a yellow
fingernail and picked his front teeth
leering at Dumbledore I could do you for
afters then waddle under normal
circumstances Dumbledore wasn't scared
of Finn you agree back Bellatrix
Lestrange Voldemort or any of the other
Death Eaters for that matter but in
these unique circumstances where he knew
death was imminent the prospect of
Fenrir Greyback
ripping apart his body was not
particularly enticing for this reason
when he pleaded with Snape he was also
speaking out of self-interest he wanted
Snape to kill him he wanted drake her
soul to be preserved he also wanted a
painless death and that's it for this
video if you enjoy the contents please
be sure to LIKE the video and subscribe
to the channel until next time
you're a wizard Harry
[Music]
you